lebron's why they call you the fire boy
cause everything that i touched fire boy
i was the one with the can of the gas
and the matches the propane the tank and
the lighter boy
i was the one with the vision yeah now
they all look at me different
now i'm the one out here making
decisions looking around i don't see
competition i just started going in but
i don't want to hurt their feelings all
these thoughts up in my head they run
under my minds a minute if i say that
i'ma do it then i really manifest it you
say you gonna do it but you probably
never did it i've been working every day
and i've been staying independent
trying my business but the flow is
unattended and the pen is getting sick
from all the venom i've been dipping and
this [ __ ] is hitting different and it
happened in an instance like damn
i just blew up off a podcast first one
to do it that's
all facts i got a shout out to brendan
shot theovan i turn comic-con to vietnam
hey
i'm dropping bombs on the regular yeah
now they all hit in my cellular yeah
still with no label no manager just got
a gift like that boy and a manager oops
i'm in manger the flow is in danger my
peers are in danger read him a prayer i
just found my angle and got to the green
a man i just teed off with no l like
decatur i'm right out the gate
keeping it player but whenever i get
done they all seem scared for the
billy's i will lash out like the girl
with the green hair flow so premiere
damn
that boy flow god level but i never sold
my soul to the devil i grew up on bone
thugs and heavy metal from the bottom of
ohio and i kick it with my idols like
what
guess i'm a glitch in the system i'm
hacking the matrix i'm different yeah
i just broke the simulation then
who is this boy in here going off man
let's pull his car we don't know his
name
kev said you gotta go all in i told him
bet like a poker game
they said i'm trying to be lil dicky i
told him i promise i'm not
dave i'm just a nobody that got a chance
then wrote his first album in five days
they gassed me up and say movie then
screenshot my [ __ ] to their friends and
it's all shade
but when they see me in person they
don't really say [ __ ] it turns to a
quiet place
i feel like i haven't started yet but i
had to give them a little taste
the king in the stink [ __ ] was cool but
they ain't heard my real [ __ ] man
fireboy on the way browser
[Music]
you